when you mentioned Hamas knew this was
going to happen do you think they knew I
mean you're you're outlining this this
this story of Domino's falling over
which could lead to World War I and the
first thing I thought was if you are
Hamas in Gaza you're thinking World War
I is is is our only path to any kind of
change well look again I think World War
II is a little hyper I I don't foresee
Russia getting involved although it
could happen something like that we're
already in a massive proxy war against
Russia right now as we all know which is
uh horrifying and terrifying um but
they're not that close with the
Ayatollah you know Russia and Iran they
have their own tensions going back and
they've been getting along okay and and
Iran has been sending drones for the
Russian war effort and that kind of
thing but they don't have like a treaty
of Alliance where Russia would go to war
for Iran and quite frankly I think
I think worst case scenario here the war
spreads to Lebanon and possibly Iraq but
I really think that the
Americans and and the ayat Tois guys too
have got to be cautioning him and I
think the American Military has got to
be telling Joe Biden how badly they do
not want to fight Ira Iran you put that
map up earlier there that country's what
three four times the size of Afghanistan
Afghanistan is the size of Texas okay
people don't understand this too um
that's why I say geography lesson and
this is mountains too topography lesson
counts too this isn't flat desert like
Iraq you cannot win here man mountains
massive with massive air defense the US
military Doctrine is is defined by its
air superiority I I I really now I don't
know how much I believe that there is a
is a war with Iran coming like whether
cooler heads will prevail or not but I
strongly believe that if it does happen
the US will justify using tactical
nuclear weapons because they'll they'll
want to take out the oil reserves
they'll want to take because that's what
Lindsey Graham's after or they'll use
moabs as big as they possibly can if
they don't want to get on they don't
want what do you make of Iran having um
trained Hamas
Fighters well look I mean they have a a
real interest in disrupting the
situation in Israel and Palestine you
really want I me Iran was training Hamas
Fighters before were even Hamas like
back in the late 80s when Hamas was
essentially forming in yeah in Lebanon
with Hezbollah so well
no that's different yeah Hamas Hamas is
yeah and they're they're part of the
Muslim Brotherhood and I want to
recommend to you and and to everyone
listening a great book by Robert drus
called Devil's game how the United
States helped unleash fundamentalist
Islam so it's the US's fault that the
the extr yes because America inherited
all of the European and the Japanese
World Empires after World War II America
is the dominant force in the Middle East
even though we're the middle part of
North created the people that hate us
now is that I'm just trying to
understand what you're saying not not
created in the like oversimplified sense
but yes the enemy in the Cold War was
first the commies and second the
nationalists
and who's opposed to both the commies
and the nationalists the
islamists and so America and Britain and
Saudi Arabia spent billions spreading
fundamentalist Islam throughout the
region and not just the wahhabism of
Saudi but the Muslim Brotherhood
essentially was meant to disrupt all
secular politics in the region for
generations and did so that was the
purpose of it and that was why America
back the Muslim Brotherhood that was a
huge part of the reason of course that
America and Saudi worked together to
send a bunch of guys Proto alqaeda guys
to fight the Soviets in Afghanistan in
the 1980s which is where those that's
right well because see there was the
Afghan mujahadin but then there was the
Arab Afghan Army and these were
mercenaries again look at the map all of
these guys are Arabs then you have
Persia and then you have the Afghans who
are hazaras and tajiks and USCS and
tunes right they're not Arabs at all so
they sent they got all these Arabs to
come and sent them to fight in
Afghanistan including the guys who were
the leaders of what became Islamic Jihad
and al- Qaeda that ended up turning
against the United States so and in fact
most people don't know this but
throughout the 1990s when Al Qaeda was
already attacking the United States Bill
Clinton kept supporting them anyway he
supported them in Bosnia and in Kosovo
and in cnia and you might Remember When
Vladimir Putin declared war on Ukraine
two and a half or a year and a half ago
in his declaration of war he said and
it's I like the way he did this too
because he knew it was going to sound
like conspiracy stuff so he phrased it
like this he goes come on let's be
adults about this we know what you and
Britain were doing in
Chia right that was true America was
supporting bid ladite head chopper
suicide bomber murderers
R out in Brooklyn I mean well and and
and his men uh were essentially divided
right there was this this they were
motivated to attack the United States by
one our stationing of troops in Saudi
Arabia two in order to bomb Iraq from
1990 all the way through okay through
the entire Clinton years and then
support for Israel in their in their
occupations of Palestine and at that
time of Southern Lebanon as well as
support for all the dictatorships in the
region so even though Bill Clinton was
backing them in Kosovo and in Chia they
were still coming for us anyway he was
using them but he wasn't buying their
loyalty and so I'm not like a 9911 truth
here saying the CIA had them attack us
that's not right but what happened was
they were too clever by half just like
Netanyahu they think they're so smart
we're going to back these terrorists and
then I'll tell you I got I got these
great uh quotes for you guys
okay this one is from the American
Pentagon in the years before September
11th they said terrorism is a small
price to pay for being a
superpower okay and what they were
thinking was come on somebody sets off a
truck bomb at an embassy in Africa or
something who cares we get to rule the
world okay here's a quote just like that
Libby that you can find from from
Benjamin Netanyahu addressing the
leaders of his party the
lud and he's talking about
we anyone who wants to thwart the
establishment of a Palestinian state has
to support bolstering
Hamas in Gaza hey because they will
never deal but then he said we control
the height of the flame right it's that
same Imperial arrogance of the Bill
Clinton years that we can use these
people to keep things the way we want
whether to fight our enemies or to
divide and conquer our subject peoples
but then what are they going to do right
in fact one more quote was from uh a
female Israeli soldier who warned her
Superior officers that Hamas is training
they're obviously training hard they're
preparing something and her boss one sec
her boss told her breaking news breaking
news they're punks they won't do
anything NBC Boston is reporting that uh
the main and Main shooter Robert cter
has been located and is dead oh damn
where is he all good uh they I don't
know I'm just looking at it right now
this is uh the man suspected in
Wednesday's Massacre that killed 18
people in Leon Maine has been found dead
sources told NBC Boston investigators
Friday night Robert C was the subject of
days long of a days long manhood that
followed mass shootings at the Justin
Time Recreation bowling alley and
means Bar and Grill schmies schmies all
right um you're from New Hampshire you
should know pronounce things it's it's
literally schans I know it's very weird
it'sme anyway um specific details are
not available immediately but the
sources told nbc1 Boston investigators
that there is no longer a threat in
Maine as card has been located and is
deceased that is literally just popped
up like five minutes ago I just wanted
to say you know because we we talk a lot
about this deep history with the Middle
East and US involvement and it kind of
feels like uh a lot of the conversation
I've had I'm always just like someone
will make a bunch of points about well
this you know Libby says these people
hate us and then you're talking about
these these operations and I'm just like
would we would we not benefit from not
being involved like is it better for us
we just totally not be involved 100% And
so when I hear a lot of like moral
arguments well like what they're doing
this and they're doing this and then you
know the Israel Palestine stuff
specifically I'm kind of like my
response is I'm America I don't know why
we're arguing with the morality of
foreign Nations that are in a
generational conflict
should the answer is the answer is
because America is the world Empire Tim
and this is a huge contradiction right
this is the new world our ancestors came
here so they can mine their own business
and be free and yet America came out on
top at the end of the second world war
the rest of the industrialized world was
burnt to the ground and so America had
what half the GDP of the planet and then
they took full advantage and they
created a world Empire they Justified it
in the name of containing the Soviet
Union and then when the Soviet Union
ceased to exist 30 years ago what' they
do quit and go get a real job no they
went and they expanded to the Middle
East they expanded into Eastern Europe
and they picked a fight with al- Qaeda
and they picked a fight with Russia and
now here we are let same as they
expanded by the way you guys are such
China Hawks on here but who started the
China pivot that was Barack Hussein
Obama and Hillary Clinton who said now's
time to pick a fight with China that was
their policy
I just want to you know my my view and
it's probably naive it's probably
ignorant whatever but my view is a
tremendous opportunity of the fall of
the Soviet Union for trade agreements
and not war right to to to say hey we're
you know you look at what's going on in
Eastern Europe and we keep hearing from
The Establishment press and from the
neocon neolib unip party that it's an
unprovoked invasion of Ukraine and
Russia oh come on NATO expansion that's
my book is called provoked it's about
how they provoked but at the very least
if you want to make the argument that uh
you know I was in Ukraine at the start
of the protests which which eventually
turned into the yanukovich and in the
city I talked to many random people what
did I find they were very Pro proe and
the when I talk to them they say that
what I what I was generally told by a
lot of ukrainians was you know Russia
wants to re create this fed this Trade
union they want Ukraine to be a part of
it Ukraine many ukrainians don't trust
Russia obviously because so wasn't even
that long ago so a lot of the older
folks are really concerned and entering
the EU is a major economic lift up and
the shenen Zone A lot of people want to
move and so that's where where we're
going that is that is all geopolitical
dispute and conflict which results in
escalated conflict the idea that there's
no provocation uh uh what the media keep
saying is just absurd as as long as our
military alliances are expanding in a
region there is cause for conflict right
you're absolutely right and look this
isn't just hindsight okay this is what
all the Paleo conservatives said 30
years ago Pat Buchanan and you know
Scott McConnell and all the guys who
were like the refugees from the George
HW Bush Republican party at that time
Ron Paul ran for president in 1988
saying we need to completely back out of
the old world altogether and was
absolutely right and and you know what
happened HW Bush took full advantage he
lied to the Russians he knew the plan
was to expand NATO and they lied to the
Russians and made them believe that they
wouldn't expand NATO just to get them
out of the way you know what I love
you're obviously familiar they lied us
into Iraq War I as well you're obviously
familiar with a liberal economic order
sure so you know Ian brings that up
quite a bit and we've pulled up the
Council on Foreign Relations website
outlining the liberal economic order and
plainly stating is said after World War
II the fears of expanded uh war and
nuclear Annihilation led to this idea of
the liberal economic order which is a
soft way of saying American Empire
military bases everywhere the American
World Poli and it's it's an
impossibility naturally what you're
doing is creating something that becomes
the massive Target you the the US never
had the capability of suppressing the
rise of any other economic power though
they try it doesn't happen and now we're
staring at the fourth turning World War
I whatever you want to call it and it's
what my favorite part is you get to the
point where you get HW Bush saying what
was his quote we we can begin to see a
new world order mhm now you get a bunch
of people complaining about the idea of
the New World Order which literally is a
reference to an expansion upon the CFR
the liberal economic order into a new
version of it which is American World
Police Etc the media Runs Out full speed
screaming the conspiracy theory of the
New World Order and what I think happens
is a lot of people fall victim to this
there's a legitimate concern over over
powerful interests internationally
corporate interests and their and their
uh uh their um vassals in government to
create and maintain the liberal economic
order and their new version of it what
happens then is the media because these
people are easily they're stupid and
they're evil for not not every single
one but a lot of them they will take the
legitimate story of the liberal economic
order pull the most absurd claims off
the internet create this psychotic
conspiracy theory and then say anybody
who's saying this believes the crazy
conspiracy theory yeah to try and
discredit the idea that there are people
who are actually calmly and rationally
saying you know the thing you've been
doing for a long time about trying to
set up military bases everywhere to be a
World Police I think it's a bad idea
that's going to get us all killed they
say what he actually believes that
lizard people have set up a base in the
Denver Airport and he's insane don't
listen to him right look you're right
and look the the New World Order when HW
Bush said it what he meant was the era
of the American Empire and no one can
oppose us now as he put it what we say
goes thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at timcast
for uncensored membersonly shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time